pourquoi la russie piétinent en ukraine
on en débat tout de suite avec mes
invités christine dubois 1 clément
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes chercheur en
géopolitique pour la chaire risque de
l'institut d'administration des
entreprises de paris 1 panthéon sorbonne
et auteur de ce livre influencé
manipulation des conflits modernes aux
guerres économiques c'est chez v à
édition j'accueille également christian
makarian essayiste et chroniqueur
internationale au point bonsoir bonsoir
et christian soler avec pons vous êtes
journaliste grand reporter auteur d'une
biographie de vladimir poutine intitulé
poutine c'est tout simple essai publié
chez calmann-lévy l'été siècle pas
évidemment y rester à mes côtés je vais
je vais démarrer sur la vraiment là la
diplomatie emmanuel macron qui maintient
le lien avec le président russe
christine dubois clément entretien
téléphonique que c'était le premier
depuis à peu près un mois j'ai posé une
question presque provocatrice à quoi ça
sert ça sert à garder le canal ouvert en
se disant qu'il va bien falloir à un
moment ou à un autre même si dans
l'immédiat on voit bien que les choses
ne sont pas mûrs pour aller sur des
négociations ne serait ce que sur un
cessez-le-feu il n'y a pas réellement
d'appétence ni d'un côté une l'aude pour
des raisons différentes certaines
certains dont l'ukraine estime qu'il
faut pouvoir essayer de mener une
contre-offensive ou regagner du
territoire la russie elle a besoin
d'avoir une transformation de
l'opération militaire en victoire
politique et pouvoir arriver avec
suffisamment de force à une table des
négociations voire de capitulation
négocier puisque là aussi les termes les
termes ont leur poids et on aura besoin
de garder des canaux de discussion pour
essayer d'avoir cette capacité de
médiation c'est le rôle qui a été pris
par le président de la république
français d'autres états ont essayé
d'avoir cette cette capacité de canal de
médiation et puis faut pas oublier que
historiquement la france a été
particulièrement impliqué dans
l'histoire récente ukrainienne et ses
problèmes avec son grand voisin russe
quand bien même ils n'étaient pas
officiellement impliqué puisque la
guerre dans le donbass a démarré depuis
2014 et que nous sommes partie prenante
des accords de minsk 2 du format
normandie qui sont des principes de
négociation qui essayait
sans succès de mettre fin à cette guerre
quand elle était content cantonné dans
le territoire donc du don de basse et
avec avec les républiques autoproclamées
de donetsk est lougansk mais qui était
déjà à l'époque soutenu par la russie
mais dans les faits il ya une logique
historique d'une certaine logique de 10
ans à kobe steel est une nécessité de
d'essayer de pouvoir pousser et amené au
moment où ça sera mieux d'essayer de
faire les choses écrit sur ma carrière
emmanuel macron est moins virulent qu'un
job haydn par exemple dans sa façon de
parler de bloody mary t-il est-ce qu'on
pourrait presque pas je sais pas si ça
se ce s'organise d'une certaine façon
entre eux à côté good cop bad cop
mauvais fini le bon flic dans la façon
de discuter avec le président russe non
je ne crois pas que ça fasse l'objet
d'une concertation aussi précise c'est
un point qui vient en complément de ce
que vient de dire christine dubois
clément en plus le fait de garder le
contact et le canal diplomatique ouvert
c'est une manière pour la france d'
exprimer une voix légèrement différente
j'ai pas dit une dissonance meslois
différentes par exemple monsieur maiden
a commencé par dire qu'il n'enverrait
pas de troupes au tout début du conflit
un jour ou deux jours après le
déclenchement d internet en une erreur
là et dès le 25 ou 26 février ce qui a
incité poutine certaine manière à passer
à la phase violente puis il y a eu le
choc émotionnel des horaires des
atrocités des crimes de guerre commises
abuja l'opinion américaine s'est
retournée elle était à 72% contre toute
forme d'implication de militaires
américains sur le terrain ukrainien
l'opinion sait transformer ce que les
dictateurs ne comprennent pas c'est que
l'opinion publique et le buick change
puisqu'ils n'ont pas d'opinion publique
est là mathieu badel n'a cessé d'évoluer
il a utilisé le terme de boucher il a
utilisé une formule très maladroite en
dix ans un homme ne peut pas rester au
pouvoir ce qui a fait tout de suite
penser à une position de régime chez
nietzsche de renversement du régime il a
fallu que la maison blanche rétropédaler
disent non non il s'agit surtout pas de
renverser vadimir poutine puis il a
parlé du génocide et sur tous ces points
emmanuel macron à corriger ni à ford il
avait embauché je n'utiliserai pas ce
terme personnellement génocide c'est une
définition internationale très précises
ce n'est pas de la politique voilà
exactement ce qu'elles diminuent elles
mâcon ce n'est pas un terme politique à
usage politique c'est une définition
juridique très précise et pour l'instant
elle n'est pas qualifiée donc elle n'est
pas d'usagé
et de fil en aiguille médiane macron est
en train de dessiner une autre voie
alors c'est vrai que jusqu'au 1er
juillet encore un peu moins de deux mois
il préside le conseil de l'union
européenne a dit dans ses fondements de
la présidence du conseil de l'union
européenne voilà donc ils ne peuvent pas
parler tout seul hors de la france mais
quand même il ya une différence alors le
seul écueil je termine avec ça c'est
qu'il n'a pas avec lui c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire les polonais et
d'autres gouvernements des pays d'europe
centrale qui lui reprochent justement
l'autre on va modérer on y viendra ce
sera l'un des chapitres du débat
évidemment la question de l'europe
frédéric pons peut-être un focus sur
vladimir poutine est ce que l'on parle
en fait dans une forme d'isolement d'un
chef d'état qui entourent encore le
président russe qui a éventuellement de
l' influence sur lui là je parle de
deûle interne je parle pas des chefs
d'état est rude je comprends bien on dit
souvent que poutine est isolé moi je ne
le crois pas il a au kremlin en tout cas
toute une série de deux groupes qui le
suivent depuis 20 ans maintenant des
gens notamment de saint pétersbourg
aider des gens issus des services de
sécurité il ya eu un peu de
renouvellement mais pas tant que ça son
ministre des affaires étrangères lavrov
est là depuis depuis plus de 15 ans je
crois quelque chose comme ça
et ce qui est intéressant quand on
arrive à comprendre un peu comment
fonctionne le kremlin et l'architecturé
du pouvoir au sommet en russie c'est que
finalement poutine est au centre des
différents groupes il arbitre alors dire
que poutine est un centriste ça
paraîtrait un peu fou mais malgré tout
dans le jeu politique au kremlin il a
autour de lui des faucons il a des gens
qui veulent à tout prix faire la guerre
qui veulent l'affrontement avec
l'occident mais il a aussi des gens qui
sont un peu plus modérées un peu plus
libéraux ce soit sur le plan sécuritaire
ou sur le plan économique et depuis
vingt ans poutine joue avec ses
différentes forces c'est lui qui a la
voix décisionnaires évidemment donc il
est au courant de beaucoup de choses
beaucoup d'informations lui remonte sans
doute pas tous sans doute pas tout mais
on peut faire confiance à vladimir
poutine qui vous le savez est un ancien
des services pour avoir su entretenir
dans les forces de sécurité notamment et
y compris dans l'armée pas seulement
dans les services secrets des réseaux
qui lui font remonter des informations
je pense qu'il ya mieux à faire mais
qu'on le croit chez nous mais ça veut
dire qu'il ya des voix dissonantes qui
peuvent s'exprimer qu'il ne règne pas
uniquement par la terreur waouh par la
peur qui nourrit plus auprès d'eux je ne
crois pas il est il est un chef d'état
autoritaire il est très pragmatique il
sait écouter il s'est décidé les voit
lui-même serait prêt à accepter des voix
discordantes le problème ce sont les
subordonnés hostiles eux mêmes à porter
les mauvaises nouvelles au président il
faut être courageux surtout dans
l'ambiance actuelle dans cette guerre
qui n'est pas essentielle quetigny
fissiles et l'autocensure fait que
poutine le sait il est il est aussi très
psychologue il sait que parmi ses
subordonnés ce qui serait
potentiellement porteur de mauvaises
nouvelles vont hésiter à le faire et
donc c'est à lui et je pense qu'il le
fait de susciter y compris dans des
entretiens individuels de susciter ce
retour d'informations intéressantes si
ça veut dire une question à vous poser
il y avait cette rumeur alors je sais
pas si tu es une hypothèse je pas qu'on
peut la santé et non deux
testé pour plus tard maintenant d'un
renversement qui viendraient justement
de l'intérieur du kremlin d'une d'une
franche de
rêve occidental ouais je crois un peu
vous donner la réponse on peut on peut
évidemment
supposer que la personnalité de poutine
depuis 20 ans suscite des oppositions on
peut supposer que les déboires
rencontrés en ukraine
renforce un peu ces oppositions internes
de là imaginer un renversement
franchement je ne le crois pas parce que
vu d'ici vu d'occident dans l'impression
que la russie sans bourque le pouvoir
est fragilisé mais à moscou ça n'est pas
du tout la même perception il quand il
quand il regarde la carte que ce soit
les civils ou les militaires il voit que
malgré les quelques difficultés et bien
l'armée russe a réussi à conquérir un
corridor a réussi à conquérir quasiment
un cinquième du territoire ukrainien
notamment le fameux don basque alors en
train de gambe et donc pour eux il ya
une victoire chèrement acquise mais ya
quand même justement va vous m'offrez la
transition parce qu'on va maintenant
parler de 2
de la situation militaire est ce qu'on
peut parler d'échec vous avez commencé à
y répondre de l'armée russe christine du
moins clément vous avez si une tribune
dans le monde sur sur la situation de
l'armée et notamment des soldats des des
jeunes russes de leur état d'esprit
qu'est ce qu'on sait de de l'état
d'esprit de ces de ces deux jeunes
russes et peut-être tiens ça c'est ce
qui m'a le plus frappé dans votre
tribune d'où vient-il est-ce qu'ils sont
représentatifs de l'ensemble de la
russie alors il faut savoir que en
russie vous avez ce que l'on appelle des
grandes conscription donc finalement un
service militaire qui dure à peu près un
an donc il ya deux vagues une à
l'automne et une au printemps donc on
est en plein dans la dans la vague de
conscription qui a démarré le 1er avril
et qui va finir courront courant juillet
ces vagues de conscription c'est à peu
près 40 145 mille hommes donc c'est
quand même extrêmement important et ce
que l'on a vu donc dans les premières
phases de l'invasion de l'ukraine c'est
qu'il y avait énormément de conscrits
dans l'est les forces qui ont été
employées avec certains qui visiblement
ça n'était pas réellement préparé alors
déjà un conflit de haute intensité
puisque les remontées qui semblait être
est revenue au kremlin ne faisait pas
acte ou du moins n'anticipait pas la
réaction ukrainienne tant militaires que
de la population et des volontaires donc
s'attendait beaucoup plus à avoir un
accueil un peu bras ouverts de
libérateur face rappelez-vous la
terminologie à un régime nazi et
oppresseur ce qui n'a pas du tout été le
cas on l'a vu il ya eu au contraire une
réaction et une une résistance
extrêmement forte est ce que l'on a vu
aussi c'est des erreurs de gestion c'est
à dire que cette armée est là avancez en
étirant notamment céline logistique
c'est à dire en avançant très fortement
en étant du coup victime est bien
d'opérations à ses visées de harcèlement
et craignant qu'ils sont allés toucher
et bien l'approvisionnement alors que ce
soit des hommes et là on va parler
nourriture on va pas on va parler
structuration quotidienne de carburant
pour les véhicules donc il ya eu
énormément de pertes il ya eu
visiblement des cas de désertion des
quatre véhicules qui ont été abandonnées
parce que plus de carburant donc il ya
eu énormément de problématiques comme ça
et les témoignages que l'on ait pu avoir
deux par certains prisonniers donc de
l'armée de l'armée russe fait part par
les ukrainiens ce qui d'ailleurs a été
soulignée par la russie comme ne
respectant pas le droit de la guerre et
des prisonniers puisqu'il donnait les
identités des militaires pour que les
familles puissent retrouver bien les
hommes de leur famille les fils les
frères
que sais-je les marines est ce que l'on
a vu c'est et bien des hommes souvent
mal préparés en tout cas un conflit de
haute intensité cela dit qu'ils
s'attendaient à voir un conflit de haute
intensité sur les territoires
géographiques européens restent assez
peu de assez peu de gens et finalement
des sommes assez mal préparé et pas
forcément extrêmement bien formés on va
y revenir je vous repose à la question
de leur représentativité par rapport au
brent il est notamment de certaines
minorités qui est ni qui sont
représentés mais je m'ennuie reviendra
pas ce que j'aurais donné la parole sur
la question toute simple est ce que vous
êtes peut-être pas d'accord on va voir
est-ce que l'armée russe est en train de
perdre cette guerre je commence avec
vous christian makarian et ensuite de ma
part alors au sens opérationnel on peut
parler ce que font les américains déjà
des chèques stratégique pour deux
raisons il faut rester très concret
d'abord il est clair et net que la
première phase de l'opération visé une
sorte de blitzkrieg avec la prise de
kiev la capitale et que qui avait tant
en droite ligne dans l'alignement de la
frontière biélorusse avec une route
toute droite au bord de laquelle se
trouve d'ailleurs la centrale de
tchernobyl il suffisait de foncer tout
droit et d'y arriver il y avait un but
c'était juste à côté de kiev au nord de
kiev et une quinzaine qui rêve de
prendre l'aéroport
ce tome est cet aéroport devait une fois
qu'ils étaient pris servir à organiser
très vite en 48 heures un pont aérien
moyennant quoi approvisionnements et
toutes les difficultés que vient
d'écrire christine du basculement aurait
été résolu a lieu carburant etc mais il
y aussi une façon peut-être sans
cependant aurait fait le point à rien et
c'était réglé sauf que les russes ont
pris cet aéroport les ukrainiens leurs
prix de façon très surprenante
les russes longue et j'en fais
d'ailleurs un carrelage sur les troupes
russes
héliporté qui avaient été posés là puis
les russes ont repris cet aéroport et en
le reprenant ils ont détruit anéanti
inutilisable exploser toutes les pistes
y compris un exemplaire unique du plus
grand avion du monde ce qui du point de
vue de l'aéronautique est littéralement
criminelle pour les amateurs ah le
fameux 29 dont j'oublie numéro
d'ailleurs c'est pas très grave 1500
ça c'est le premier échec stratégie dont
vous parlez donc ça c'est le premier
échec stratégique ensuite il se déplie
il se redéploie 1 et ils se concentrent
tactiquement sur l'ès tu le donnes basse
et là la question c'est de reprendre à
peu près la totalité de la surface non
pas des républiques séparatistes mais
des oblast administratives des régions
de donetsk de lougansk ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire et puis troisième
objectif d'opérer une jonction avec le
sud mario paul et en milieu et d'aller
jusqu'au cri mais bon moi je concède
qu'une seule chose c'est qu'à la proche
de la fête patriotique du 9 mai qui
célèbrent la victoire de 1945 glorieuses
il est vrai
ils sont loin de cet objectif là alors
peut-être qu'ils vont célébrer la prise
la chute de marioupol je n'en sais
absolument rien puisque une offensive
d'envergure est en cours pendant 15 ans
a commencé à marion soldes enfin en est
quand même encore est loin de la
jonction avec la crimée mais ça semble
quand même être cela
l'opération alors j'ai fini
en un mot il y à échec stratégique
c'est ce que considère les américains
parce que tout simplement les objectifs
tels qu'ils ont peu les déduire puisque
ils nous communiquent pas leurs
objectifs
je premièrement ils changent et
deuxièmement ils sont pas tous d'accord
non mais moi je crois c'est un beau
récit où on sent l'inspiration
américaines ont très bien mais est-ce
que c'est la réalité bah oui est ce que
c'est la réalité qui sait exactement
quels étaient les objectifs de la russie
on peut supposer qu'ils voulaient
effectivement faire tomber le pouvoir
s'emparer de kiev est neutralisée
l'ukraine mais il s'était pas les seuls
objets pas aller sinon quand même non
on peut supposer oui mais c'était un des
objectifs plus que je suppose et gris un
ânon il y avait plusieurs objectifs
aujourd'hui on le sait bien rentre mais
l'envoie iran pays pareil c'est certain
mais c'est justement ça correspond à une
blitzkrieg ça correspond à une
séparation et je pense oui je pense que
oui ils ont échoué dans ces lieux non
mais ils ont échoué mais ça veut pas
dire qu'ils ont perdu la guerre et
qu'ils ont perdu leurs objectifs
stratégiques abc en réalité il avait
plusieurs objectifs
kiev le gouvernement remplacé l'équipe
peut zelensky par des gens clairement ça
a échoué mais leur objectif le plus
évident en tout cas aux yeux de la
population russe c'était de réussir à
recréer cette nouvelle russie dans l'est
de l'ukraine à partir du donbass et de
la crimée en constituant ce fameux
corridor c'est ce qu'ils sont en train
de réussir et le corridor est
aujourd'hui constitué il ya une
continuité entre la crimée en mono sud
et messi ezio mme sayeh lisicki jiu
mélisey l'envoyé spécial du figaro qui a
fait un très bon papier qui a suivi
toute la route suivie par les russes
aujourd'hui ce sont des zones libérées
disent les russes aient occupé
reconnaissent les ukrainiens la dernière
bataille qui va permettre à poutine de
remplir cet objectif stratégique c'est
la prise effectivement la mario paul
c'est fini mais c'est la prise du reste
du donbass qui leur échappe avec à peu
près dix neuf prise au piège
encore une fois le 9 mai c'est une date
un peu mythique très occidental pour les
russes c'est important ils n'ont pas
besoin d'une victoire pour célébrer le 9
mai pour eux la grande victoire la
grande bataille c'est 1945 et on va
avoir un million de gens dans les rues
de moscou qui vont célébrer la grande
armée russe qui a gagné en 45,6 en plus
dans le discours officiel poutine peut
dire nous avons libéré le don de base
nous tenons la crimée et une partie de
l'ukraine c'est gagné à vous la parole
est ensuite question moi j'aurais
j'aurai une approche peut-être un petit
peu un petit peu entre vous deux
messieurs si vous me le si vous me le
permettez ce qui est clair c'est qu'au
début il ya eu un flou quant aux
objectifs de guerre du kremlin quand ils
ont démarré cette invasion donc quand
ils nous on a été dans énormément
beaucoup de supputations qu'est-ce que
quand on parle du donbass est ce qu'on
parle des territoires des républiques
autoproclamées ou des oblast comme vous
l'avez clairement dit puisque
géographiquement n'était pas sur les
mêmes on était beaucoup plus vu qu'il y
avait cette terminologie de
dénazification de neutralisation et de
démilitarisation dans une approche de
régime chaîne gens donc de faire tomber
le régime 2 qui pour le remplacer par
quelque chose qui soit beaucoup plus
moscou compatible nous dirons cela ainsi
sous une forme ou sous une autre il
apparaît que effectivement dans le
développement rapide ça n'a pas
fonctionné comme prévu et ce que l'on
voit et là à mon avis il ya quelque
chose qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
n'est pas dans une guerre officiellement
déclaré on est dans une opération
militaire spéciale ce que ça veut dire
qu'il faut dire que le terme guerre est
toujours interdite dans les médias
russes paris moscou vous dira qu ils ne
sont pas bien vu qu'ils n'ont pas fait
de déclaration de guerre officiel ce qui
sur le papier est juste et que la
terminologie des opérations spéciales ne
correspond pas à quelque chose du droit
militaire et l' avantage quand vous êtes
là dedans c'est que ça vous permet de
revoir vos objectifs et de les revoir
potentiellement à la baisse ce qui
permet aussi de pouvoir les atteindre et
quand on voit notamment les déclarations
qui ont été faites il ya à peu près 15
jours par le général minea cov et qui
vous dit que là les objectifs et là pour
le coup ils sont énoncées de manière
claire certes pas par vladimir poutine
mais néanmoins par un général d'armée
qui vous dit que il faut récupérer et
donc sauver les territoires du don de
base qu'il faut avoir ce couloir le long
des mer d'azov et de la mer noire de
d'étouffer économiquement l'ukraine et
qu' il se garde la possibilité d'une
sortie en transnistrie dans le cas où
des populations russophones seraient
maltraités que ça c'est le déclarer
général mis les cailloux mais exactement
sur les sur les nazis ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
réussi à enlever les nazis de kiev bon
il y en avait y en avait pas en revanche
ce qui était à marioupol d'antan dans un
pantalon mais la termine le jeu et ça
c'est vraiment le terme est de pouvoir
le baltic à
une toute petite minorité deux ou trois
pour cent qui ont voté pour pour des
méchants non non on ne va pas le refaire
je parle pas de cela je parle du
bataillon azoff dont les origines sont
dans l'extrême droite nationaliste et
néonazis ukrainienne personne ne le nie
mais où sont ils ils sont à marioupol
ils sont dans le donbass et céder des
forces d'élite de l'armée ukrainienne et
quand poutine va pouvoir dire à
l'opinion russe nous avons anéanti le
bataillant azoff tout le monde
comprendra qu ils ont anéanti les nazis
la force nazis et craignent n et c'est
sûrement cela c'est
d'abord c'est pas tout à fait réalisé
donc là on peut faire du wishful
thinking mais quand même et a des
limites ça n'est pas fait et ce qui est
frappant ce n'est pas que ce soit fait
et que ce soit à l'intention des russes
personne n'en doute c'est la résistance
parce que ça ça n'était pas prévu la
résistance et les ukrainiens n'était pas
prévue par l'état major russe à aucun
niveau voilà et c'est l'inconvénient
d'appeler ça une opération militaire
spéciale c'est qu'on a affaire à des
terroristes
ce qui d'ailleurs permet à certaines
troupes
indisciplinés mal commandé de commettre
des crimes de guerre parce que justement
c'est pas des militaires qui combattent
ce sont des terroristes c'est comme ça
qu'ils sont qualifiés wardé nazif tiens
voilà c'est que vous êtes sur des gens
qui sont qualifiés d' une terminologie
qui nous peut nous faire un peu sourire
quand ce n'est pas la même et qui
déshumanise donc à partir vous pouvez
complètement à la légitime les oxydants
je roule avec un char sur une automobile
en train d'être conduite par un
conducteur civile à la limite c'est un
être humain tellement dégradée par la
propagande que je me rends même pas
compte des crimes odieux et du cru
banyuls qui s'est produit à bout de
chaque camp même donc pas le jeu terminé
est resté sur les faits oui la parole de
monsieur lavrov ou bien ce que qui a
filtré de la conversation entre vladimir
poutine emmanuel macron aux gens même en
début d'après-midi démontre dans le
phrasé même que les russes fonte eux
avoue une certaine surprise quand
monsieur lavrov et monsieur poutine le
confirme 10 si vous voulez arrêter cette
guerre il vous faut convaincre vos
copains entre guillemets ukrainien
d'arrêter la guerre et il faut que vous
cessiez de la offrir de leur livrer du
matériel
c'est une manière en creux de dire que
ce qui a été fait par les occidentaux et
terriblement efficace
allez je voudrais vous entendre parce
que moi ça m'a vraiment intéressé dans
votre tribune c'est cette question de
deux des minorités ethniques de
l'audition en fait ce que l'on voit
c'est qu'il ya quelque chose de très
ambivalents au niveau de la population
russe par rapport à son armée donc il ya
eu effectivement un renforcement très
fort du patriotisme de tout ce qu'on
pouvait avoir sur le pouvoir fort la
glorification des armes mais au moment
de la conscription ça reste quand même
un sujet extrêmement sensible au niveau
des familles parce que on sait et on
sait depuis la fin des années 90
notamment avec le comité des mères de
soldats que eh bien pendant la
conscription le service militaire est
très dur que les conscrits font l'objet
de violences psychologiques physiques de
privation et que on a même des zones qui
disparaissent donc ce que l'on voit
c'est que il y a une tendance ou une
tentative d'essayer d'échapper à la
conscription pour beaucoup et dans ce
cas là vous avez plusieurs méthodes vous
avez tout de même la corruption qui
reste endémique en russie donc quand
vous en avez les moyens la capacité et
la connaissance ma part des principes de
corruption vous pouvez vous dit oui et
pour vous en sortir vous avez aussi bien
toutes les méthodes parallèles mariage
avec une mère célibataire reprise
d'études certificat médical enfin il ya
différentes formules comme ça qui
permettent de pouvoir échapper à la
conscription et puis il ya ceux qui ne
peuvent pas soit par méconnaissance soit
par faute de moyens soit parce que pour
eux il ya aussi le cas de ceux qui sont
volontaires qui veulent partir parce
qu'ils servent leur pays parce qu'il ya
tout tout cette volonté là mais ce que
l'on voit c'est que eh bien il ya une
représentation assez forte finalement
des territoires de russie qui sont
beaucoup ou qui sont éloignées des
grandes villes et des grands centres
urbains et sociaux culturellement élevé
et où on a une forte représentativité
des minorités ethniques finalement d'une
russie qui est plus rural qui est
économiquement moins importante qui est
d'un point de vue social et éducatif
mois moins élevés et ça s'est vu
notamment sur un travail qui a repris
les noms des blessés donc parmi l'armée
russe qui étaient hospitalisés notamment
à rostov sur le don et on voit que bat
pour beaucoup on était sur des minorités
ethniques dénonce n'étaient pas
candidats classiques et intervenir is ce
conseil pour poursuivre ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est que en fait il ya une
répartition souvent ethnique des dans
les unités on sait par exemple que tout
ce qui est un fan tri d'assaut tout ce
qui est trop peu mécanisée ce sont des
jeunes issus des minorités du fin fond
de la russie disons sans aucun mépris
aucun en revanche les unités d'élite
c'est à dire dans les missiles
balistiques dans les parachutistes dans
une partie de l'infanterie de marine à
bord des bateaux ce sont des unités
issues de l'ouest de la russie donc des
unités un peu plus blanche un peu moins
sibérienne un peu moins orientale et ça
c'est important et ceux qui se sont
battus et qu'ils ont rencontrés tant de
déboires sur le terrain face aux
ukrainiens ce sont précisément ces
unités de second rang qui était pas les
meilleurs et qui ont été les plus
exposées et les plus exposition
bien équipé aussi les gars de butcher
par exemple on va faire je reprends la
main pardon parce que le temps file il
nous reste une dizaine de minutes
laetitia j'aurais qu'on parle un peu las
de la communication de l'image de
vladimir poutine la communication de la
lumière poutine elle est intéressante
car elle est totalement à rebours de nos
modèles nos codes occidentaux et c'est
peut-être une de ses premières
allocutions on voit la regarde et qui
contient toute sa communication c'était
le 24 février c'est la première image de
la guerre en ukraine où vladimir poutine
prend la parole
j'ai pris la décision d'une opération
militaire
alors beaucoup d'observateurs ont
analysé ce décor un peu désuet avec des
téléphones qui semble sortir des années
80 avec des fils des drapeaux un décor
qui c'est vrai contraste avec les vidéos
ensuite de verser linski qui a occupé
les réseaux sociaux jeux les réseaux
sociaux et dans une époque ultra
connectés on a eu tendance à dire que
vladimir poutine pouvait perdre cette
bataille de communication est en tout
cas avait un handicap par rapport à
volodimir et nasri il me semble pourtant
que in vadimir poutine
surtout a construit cette communication
à destination des russes voilà des
russes qui sont habitués à ça à sa
propagande et donc ont leurs propres
codes et il a décidé de favoriser la
télévision il n'est pas sur les réseaux
sociaux j'ai regardé il n'a même pas de
compte twitter et donc c'est à la télé
qu'il s'exprime comme le 26 avril
dernier où il disait être favorable à
des négociations
soit et un auto je te malgré le fait que
l'opération militaire soit en cours
nous espérons toujours pouvoir parvenir
à des accords par la voie diplomatique
nous négocions nous ne rejetons pas ces
négociations ni en cause
l'attitude si de poutine est
intéressante à analyser on le voit un
peu avachi là il est comme cela sur son
bureau alors là encore les analystes
s'opposent finalement vous m'avez dit on
pas par an cette émission que finalement
il perdait cette bataille de
communication parce qu'ils étaient trop
désinvolte et puis qu'il avait une
attitude encore une fois qui ne
correspond pas à notre époque il me
semble pourtant que cette image c'est
aussi un message envoyé aux occidentaux
pour bien spécifié qu'il n'adoptera
jamais nos codes qu'il reste lui sur
l'image qu'il s'est construite de du
maître du kremlin viril homme fort qui
incarne la patrie russe est juste pour
finir sa cote de popularité a augmenté
de 20% vous voyez un bond de 20% auprès
des russes entre avril entre décembre et
avril 63 83 % d'opinions favorables
voilà ça vous voulez qu'on boucle ce
cette première partie consacrée vraiment
à la russie côté diplomatie côté poutine
et côté militaire on va terminer 7
minutes 8 minutes pour parler de
l'europe que je propose à steve jourdain
de nous rejoindre tout de suite pour
voir ce qui se joue en ce moment à
bruxelles rebond soit steve elle en
europe tout le monde est d'accord sur le
principe ne plus acheter du gaz russe
mais ça bloque tableau que je la vois la
date notamment la date bloc à partir de
quand l'embargo sur le gaz russe va-t-il
entrer en vigueur en vigueur le problème
évidemment c'est que chaque pays a ses
particularités au niveau européen la
russie c'est 40 à 50% de la consommation
de gaz nous français nous sommes
beaucoup moins dépendants que d'autres
pays pour vous donner une idée le gaz
russe c'est 20 % de notre consommation
de gaz pour nos voisins italiens c'est
plus de 50% difficile dans ces
conditions de se mettre d'accord sur une
date notamment de l'embargo aujourd'hui
ce qui est acté si l'arrêt de
l'importation de charbon russes ce sera
à partir du mois d'août ça fait partie
la cinquième salve de sanctions contre
moscou quant au pétrole une décision
pourrait être prise au niveau européen
dans les jours qui viennent objectif un
arrêt des importations d'ici à la fin de
l'année demain alors on le sait en
réplique à ces sanctions européennes la
russie a décidé d'imposer le paiement en
roubles sur ces transactions de gaz et
elle a mis ses menaces à exécution
oui fini le gaz pour la pologne pour la
bulgarie les deux pays refusaient
d'ouvrir un compte en roubles du coup la
russie a suspendu ses livraisons de gaz
vers ces deux pays il faut préciser que
les contrats conclus par les compagnies
européennes doivent être payés en euros
ou en dollars c'est ce qui est écrit
noir sur blanc sur ces contrats il ya
les 27 ministres européens de l'énergie
se sont réunis en urgence à bruxelles
pour l'instant hors de question de céder
aux menaces russes
continueront de payer en euros les
contrats qui ont été stipulé en euros
en dollars ce qui ont été stipulé en
dollars et nous ne pouvons pas accepter
ce genre de manoeuvres qui sont des
manoeuvres qui rompent des contrats déjà
établis la commission européenne qui a
dit qu'il fallait se préparer à une
rupture des approvisionnements en gaz le
mot d'ordre aujourd'hui coordination
entre les pays de l'union objectif
trouver de nouveaux mécanismes de
solidarité pour éviter la panne sèche en
europe merci steve pour pour toutes ces
informations christian makarian est ce
que on commence quand même il y avait
une belle unité d'une certaine façon en
tout cas affiché par les pays européens
depuis le début de cette crise est ce
que là ce qui s'est passé avec la
bulgarie la pologne ça commence quand
même à et à mettre un coin dans cette
unité oui on vient de parler du pétrole
qui est un problème beaucoup de répit ne
que le gaz puisque le pétrole il ya un
marché oui c'est plus facile d'aller
trouver
compenser certaines
diminution par d'autres orientations sur
le gaz c'est beaucoup plus compliqué il
faut des méthaniers transformer le gaz
des installations par exemple qu'un
énorme pays industriels comme le manioc
n'a pas la france a plus de possibilités
mais tanière que la le moko l'allemagne
bon il ya toute une géographie de
l'énergie qui va se dessiner moi ce que
je constate c'est que je reste sur la
grande puissance industrielle kehl
allemagne or l'espace de deux mois
l'allemagne a diminué sa course sa
dépendance par rapport au gaz russe 2
35% c'est spectaculaire
donc tout est spectaculaire dans cette
affaire depuis le début que ce soit sur
le terrain militaire
sur le plan du désastre humain avec les
plus de 5 millions de réfugiés craignant
qu'ils se trouvent dans les pays
d'europe centrale aujourd'hui mais ce
qu'on constate aussi c'est une
divergence vous avez raison thomas il y
en a dans tous les sens aujourd'hui ou
plutôt exactement hier on a appris que
la slovaquie et la hongrie était
totalement opposé à l'embargo de l'union
sur le pétrole pourquoi l'on l'embargo
sur le pétrole parce qu'il est plus soft
encore une fois à installer que
l'embargo sur le gaz la maillot sur
lequel charbon allez un peu de soi parce
qu'on est maintenant très peu
importateurs à part la pologne et
l'allemagne nous par exemple en france
ça ne concerne pas du tout l'homme avoue
sur le charbon c'est un peu une
manoeuvre dont ici ça traîne c'est parce
qu'on n'arrive plus à se mettre d'accord
on n'est pas d'accord
entre nous il faut trouver un langage
commun et là je pense que franchement à
la france un rôle à jouer en jonction
avec l'allemagne pour essayer
d'effectuer une percée pour entraîner
les autres pays parce que en fait pour
l'instant il ya un grand désordre
géopolitique qui s'est installée la
suède et la finlande veulent rejoindre
du temps l'otan ait quitté leur statut
pourtant très installé deux pays neutre
la pologne veut voudrez livrer des chars
des t-72 qu'elle a encore à disposition
sur son sol aux ukrainiens c'est à dire
entrer dans une phase beaucoup plus
active qui nous qui ferait de nous
littéralement le pays européens déco
bélie gens ce n'est pas absolument pas
souhaitable
donc ça tire dans tous les sens accord
il manque un patron il manque un
discours et est-ce que olaf scholz et
emmanuel macron vont puisque manama
qu'on nous annonçait que
traditionnellement il a effectué sa
première visite de nouveau président en
allemagne est-ce qu'ils vont à lancer
une initiative commune dans ce sens là
moi j'ai dit qu'une chose elle serait
vraiment bienvenu
christine dugoin clément avoue le bout
de la conclusion il nous reste une
minute j'aimerais dire cela il nous
reste nous respectons la parole elle a
eu plutôt moins que vous dont christine
clément mot de conclusion là dessus sur
sur finalement la stratégie de la divers
poutine est ce que c'est une vision
occidentale de dire s'il s'est isolé
avec ce conflit ou est ce que finalement
ils trouvent pas d aller ailleurs par
exemple l'inde qui est très heureuse
d'acheter du gaz russe aujourd'hui alors
en fait il faut il faut voir les choses
de plusieurs manières d'un point de vue
occidental on a eu tendance à dire
qu'effectivement la guerre
informationnelle avait été remportée par
l'ukraine c'est vrai pour les pays
occidentaux c'est vrai pour les etats
unis c'est vrai pour le canada c'est pas
forcément aussi vrai pour d'autres pays
au moyen-orient différents pays
d'afrique et au niveau des brics ou
notamment tout ce qui a été la
rhétorique vaseuses brésil
afrique du sud
où finalement toute la rhétorique pro en
rasion donc et soutenez l'action russes
pour des raisons différentes a reçu un
accueil qui a été beaucoup plus
favorable et cet accueil l'a donc
l'effort quelque part a été portée pas
forcément sur les occidentaux mais plus
sur ces zones là qui permettent aussi
d'essayer d'avoir des voies de
dégagement des façons de bypass et les
sanctions que les occidentaux essayent
de mettre en place qu'ils ont mis assez
vite et avec il faut quand même il faut
quand même le salut et une réactivité
assez forte et une forme de consensus
tout l'enjeu maintenant pour nous ça
serait de réussir à le maintenir cet
effort sur la durée tout en sachant
qu'on a une dichotomie dans le temps
c'est à dire que les politiques
énergétiques sont des politiques de
temps long et que là on est obligé de
réagir dans un temps très court donc on
est sur des ruptures d'agenda et le
kremlin joue en règle générale très bien
des divisions haut niveau notamment des
de l'union européenne pour affaiblir la
prise de décision et le temps et c'est
là où on va avoir un véritable enjeu
dans les résultats à venir merci
beaucoup à tous merci le titre de votre
livre influencé manipulation des
conflits modernes aux guerres
économiques c'est publié chez vers
édition est le vôtre
et constantine c'est chez calmann-lévy
merci encore christian à bientôt merci
laetitia bientôt sur l'antenne de public
sénat